♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour la troisième fois
en 13 mo, , les rues
de Toronto se couvrent
de pancartes électorales.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et visiblement, la course ne
suscite pas beaucoup d'intérêt.
Des électeurs désintéressés,
une campagne tranquille.
Pourtant, dans le cas
Des électeurs désintéressés,
une campagneraranquille.
Pourtant, dans le cas
de Toronto, ce n'est pas
faute de candidats, avec
une trentaine de personnes
qui convoitent la mairie.
Mais ces nombreuses
candidatures ont été éclipsées
par celle du maire sortant,
John Tory, qui brigue
un troisième mandat.
Dans son quartier général,
quelques bénévoles font
des appels, pendant que
le maire lit son journal.
Ici, on ne sent pas
l'effervescence qui règne
souvent dans les bureaux de
campagne, car l'équipe Tory
sait qu'elle mène largement
dans les sondages.
Le maire sortant fait le pari
que l'électorat voudra miser
sur son expérience.
- - If I hadn't produced any
results, I wouldn't even be a
competitive candidate for mayor.
- "Si je n'avais pas produit
de résultats, je ne serais
pas un candidat compétitif",
affirme John Tory.
Le maire sortant se targue
d'oioir livré la marchandise.
Mais ce constat est loin d'être
partagé par tous les Torontois.
Beaucoup ont plutôt l'impression
que leur ville peine à offrir
les services de base :
pénurie de logements,
rues sales, nids de poule,
manque de pistes cyclables
et transports publics laborieux.
- When I actually look
at his policies, they are
not that progressive.
- "Ses politiques ne sont
pas assez progressistes",
croit cette Torontoise.
- What can the city do
to make...
- Des reprhehes que John Tory
a aussi entendus de la part de
ses rivaux, qui l'ont souvent
accusé de manquer d'ambition.
"Il n'a rien fait en huit ans
et le logementbobordable
est un échec", a lancé
le principal rival de
John Tory, Gil Penalosa.
- Yes, there are problems,
I'm not satisfied.
- "O, , il y a des problèmes
et je ne suis pas satisfait",
admet John Tory.
Il promet toutefois de régler
ces questions, qu'il attribue
notamment à la pandémie.
Car Toronto se relève
difficilement de la crise.
La métropole enregistre
un déficit d'environ
1 milliard de dollars,
que le maire sortant promet de
résorber sans hausse de taxes,
et ce, mmeme si Toronto
a l'un des taux d'imposition
les plus bas de la province.
- And if people think
they would like to pay more...
- "Si les gens veulent payer
plus de taxes, ils n'ont qu'à
choisir un aut c candidat",
lance John Tory.
Nous suivons le maire sortant,
alors qu'il fait campagne
en banlie e ouest de Toronto.
Dans ce restaurant somalien,
John Tory est accueilli
en vedette.Ses promesses
de réduire la violence armée
et de garder les taxes basses
séduisent visiblement.
- He built this city,
he creates jobs...
- "Il a bâti cette ville,
créé des emplois. C'est
quelqu'un qui promouvoit
la diversité", explique
cette sympathisante.
Deuxième arrêt de campagne
dans une épicerie perse
du nord de Toronto.
Ici aussi, John Tory est
entouré de visages amis et
essaie de conquérir les indécis.
Mais dans une allée,
un électeur l'intercepte.
- Don't you think
that by endorsing...
- Le citoyen reproche
au maire sortant de miner
la vie démocratique en se
présentant une troisième fois.
- J'attends de lui
de comprendre ça et quand
c'est le temps de se retirer
et donner la chance aux autres.
- John Tory est clair :
cette campagne sera sa dernière.
- Twelve years is a asasonable
time, but it's also enough.
- "Douze ans, c'est assez",
croit le maire.
Ce seraitusussi un record
de longévité à la tête de
la plus grande ville du Canada.
Mais pour ça, il faudra que
les électeurs choisissent
encore John Tory. Et rien
n'est tout à fait joué
avant le 24 octobre.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto